y
u
[Aplausos]
en 1968 eric von däniken publicó el
libro recuerdos del futuro proponiendo
la hipótesis de que varias
civilizaciones antiguas fueron visitadas
por extraterrestres quienes les
transmitieron parte de sus conocimientos
tecnológicos
las líneas de nazca en perú fueron
comparadas con aeropuertos mientras que
un sarcófago en las ruinas mayas de
palenque se decía que representaba un
viajero espacial
así pirámides monumentos y varios sitios
ancestrales fueron puestos como prueba
de la presencia alienígena en la tierra
por supuesto científicos historiadores y
académicos en general han declarado que
esto es falso pero el problema es mucho
más de fondo
varias veces pensamos que el
conocimiento indígena o el conocimiento
ancestral son menos valiosos que el
conocimiento científico occidental al
desconocer cómo las civilizaciones
antiguas han logrado hacer lo que han
hecho algunas personas prefieren creer
que fueron ayudadas por extraterrestres
que darles verdadero valor a su
conocimiento
desde que éramos niños mis hermanos y yo
compartimos con nuestros padres
soñadores incomparables su visión de
valorar y aprender del conocimiento
ancestral de nuestras comunidades
indígenas en especial dichos muy
variadas formas de organización social
relación con la naturaleza y transmisión
de conocimientos
recién el año anterior se demostró que
los pueblos indígenas ocupan una cuarta
parte de la superficie de la tierra
intersectan 40% de las áreas protegidas
del mundo para los pueblos indígenas y
no indígenas el agua es un elemento
vital dentro de las tradiciones
indígenas las prácticas de siembra y
cosecha de agua utilizan conocimiento
ancestral basado en la naturaleza por
ejemplo los sistemas de canadá en el
norte de áfrica y el medio oriente
utilizan túneles y pozos para cosechar
agua subterránea en el desierto
en la isla de pascua en chile la
ubicación de estas plataformas
megalíticas conocidas como ajo se
explica por la distancia fuentes de agua
dulce o filtros costeros que les han
permitido a los habitantes de la isla
sobrevivir y construir las estatuas
gigantes conocidas como moais
y en varias zonas montañosas del mundo
como los grandes los himalayas o los
alpes desviar agua desde ríos y
quebradas hacia zonas de alta
permeabilidad es una práctica recurrente
los sistemas de careo en españa'
construidos con los árabes entre los
siglos 9 al 15 comparten muchas
similitudes con los sistemas de monash
en perú construidos por las culturas
preincas chavín y war iii desde antes
del siglo quinto en la actualidad varias
de estas prácticas están siendo
reconocidas por las naciones unidas y
por organizaciones ambientales como
medios potenciales para proveer agua a
un mundo cada vez más poblado
uno de los casos más desafiantes es el
de la costa desértica de sudamérica en
donde varios procesos determinan dónde y
cuando el agua se distribuye en la
región
este movimiento de respiración que
ustedes ven aquí es la lluvia en los
daneses el aire húmedo viaja desde el
oriente desde la amazonía y es bloqueado
por la barrera montañosa de los dans eso
produce una gran diferencia entre el
océano pacífico y la amazonía al mismo
tiempo la corriente fría de humboldt
mantiene las condiciones secas desde el
desierto de sechura al norte de perú
hasta el desierto de atacama al norte de
chile la capital de perú lima se
encuentra en mitad de este desierto
ustedes se pueden preguntar porque él y
me estoy bueno hace 500 años los
habitantes de los pueblos originarios de
américa sí fueron visitados por sabios
seres de otro mundo
un mito cuenta que cuando los españoles
buscaban donde construir la capital de
su virreinato en la recientemente
descubierta américa a modo de venganza
por la conquista los nativos
sudamericanos les recomendaron construir
lima en la peor ubicación posible
actualmente lima con 12 millones de
habitantes es la segunda es la segunda
ciudad más grande de sudamérica luego de
sao paulo en brasil y la segunda ciudad
más grande del mundo ubicada en un
desierto luego de sao paulo perdón luego
de el cairo en egipto esto contrasta
fuertemente con las comunidades que
viven en los andes' a simple vista hay
poco en común entre el oficinista que
trabaja en su escritorio en lima y el
campesino que pastore a su ganado en la
punta de los andes peruanos pero los dos
dependen de exactamente la misma fuente
de agua
la la alta estacionalidad climática esto
es la diferencia entre la estación de
lluvias y la estación seca combinada con
los cambios en el uso del suelo aguas de
arriba tiene consecuencias igualmente
extremas para las comunidades que viven
aguas abajo sin mencionar los impactos
del cambio climático
bajo estas condiciones lima depende del
agua de tres ríos que se originan en los
llanos el problema de escasez de agua en
lima es que la temporada seca es muy
larga de 7 a 8 meses
con volúmenes de agua que no pueden
satisfacer la demanda
por otro lado la estación de lluvias es
muy corta de 4 de 3 a 4 meses con
volúmenes de agua que pueden generar
inundaciones entonces la solución está
en almacenar la mayor cantidad de agua
que se puede durante la estación de
lluvias para poder utilizarla durante la
estación seca en el último siglo esto se
ha logrado instalando 330 millones de
metros cúbicos de almacenamiento
artificial utilizando presas canales
reservorios trasvases de la amazonía y
otro tipo de infraestructura gris que es
muy costosa de construir y que tiene
impactos desastrosos sobre el medio
ambiente
y aún así le faltan 43 millones de
metros cúbicos de agua para poner este
número en contexto una piscina olímpica
tiene dimensiones de estándar de 50
metros de largo por 25 metros de ancho
por dos metros de profundidad
equivalente a 2.500 metros cúbicos de
agua 330 millones equivalen no a mil o
dos mil sino a 132 mil piscinas
olímpicas
ahora las montañas también funcionan
como torres de agua y ellas lo hacen a
través de dos mecanismos el primero es
el rendimiento o la fábrica qué
determina cuánto del agua que cae de la
lluvia se convierte en el caudal de un
río el segundo es la regulación qué
determina por cuánto tiempo el agua está
almacenada luego de la lluvia hasta que
llega a este río el balance entre estos
dos es fundamental y a veces es
malentendido por ejemplo a veces
pensamos que sembrar árboles va a
mejorar la esponja y a darnos más agua
entonces varios proyectos de forestación
cubren grandes extensiones de páramo y
de pugna con árboles los árboles
consumen más agua que la vegetación
nativa peor cuando son pinos eucaliptos
y eso simplemente reduce la producción
de la fábrica
durante siglos los habitantes de las
montañas han tenido que lidiar con esta
variabilidad climática y en huamantanga
en la sierra de lima han desarrollado
una solución muy ingeniosa desde hace
1.400 años sus habitantes utilizan el
suelo como un reservorio natural para
poder almacenar esa agua de la temporada
de lluvias y utilizarla en la temporada
seca el sistema es localmente conocido
como mama ante o que viene de la palabra
amamantar porque son las mujeres para
muchos pueblos indígenas las guardianas
del agua
esta práctica está bastante ligada a las
tradiciones culturales de sus habitantes
con mingas y rituales para poder
bendecir y abrir los canales y
compuertas de manejo de agua
cómo funciona el manteo durante la
temporada de lluvias utiliza canales que
desvían el agua a estas zonas de alta
infiltración efectivamente utilizando el
suelo como un reservorio natural el agua
viaja mucho más lentamente dentro del
suelo que sobre la superficie y es
recuperada pendiente abajo en
manantiales luego de varias semanas o
incluso meses durante cinco años un
grupo de científicos sociales y
naturales hemos investigado uno de los
últimos sistemas que aún funcionan en la
sierra del perú para conocer la
capacidad de producción de la fábrica
medimos la cantidad de lluvia que cae y
el caudal en la quebrada y encontramos
que solamente la cuarta parte de la
lluvia se convierte en caudal para
conocer la capacidad de retención de la
esponja inyectamos trazadores colorantes
en los canales de infiltración y matamos
donde y cuando éstos aparecen pendiente
abajo lo emocionante es que demostramos
o confirmamos que el sistema funciona es
decir el agua permanece almacenada
dentro del suelo entre dos semanas y
hasta ocho meses antes de salir a la
superficie
pero para la escala de lima nuevamente
este sistema es sumamente pequeño
entonces nos preguntamos qué pasaría si
es que podemos replicar el sistema de
huamantanga para toda la parte alta del
río rímac que abastece de agua a lima
generamos un modelo de simulación y
estimamos que esta práctica puede
desviar e infiltrar y recuperar casi 100
millones de metros cúbicos de agua o
40.000 piscinas olímpicas- esto es más
del doble de lo que el imán necesita
ahora durante la estación seca y que
además se pueden combinar con las otras
132 mil piscinas que ya existen en los
canales reservorios y presas
actualmente existiendo en la cuenca
el manteo es un claro ejemplo de la
capacidad y el conocimiento de las
comunidades indígenas y campesinas de
los daños
pero más allá de este ejemplo soluciones
similares que están basadas en la
naturaleza pueden y deben ser estudiadas
para poder enfrentar problemas en otros
lugares del mundo y en otras áreas de la
ciencia también
mi papá william falleció hace cinco años
más o menos cuando esta investigación
estaba empezando ahora cuando yo lo veo
reflejado en los ojos de mi mamá mariana
me pregunto cuántas niñas y niños tienen
la oportunidad de crecer con un
propósito yo no espero que ellos estén
orgullosos de mí espero que estén
orgullosos de candelaria timoteo ulises
ferrer cat ya víctor y muchas muchas
personas más que nos abrieron sus
puertas nos compartieron su alimento y
nos revelaron su conocimiento
extraterrestres yo más bien digo que son
extraordinarios muchas gracias
[Música]